I like reading what's your favorite last
book that you read H it I don't it's
like a you know what smut no like like
okay do okay it's like a book but it's
[Music]
like
hey
hey okay guys don't be nervous I'm super
easy and and you're going to be fine
you're going to be great you guys all
look like Master ridlers just a bunch of
rizzly bear energy in front of me so I'm
I'm super excited my name is Deb I'm 21
I'm from Ontario Canada I'm currently in
my third year of nursing school and I
also make YouTube videos sometimes how
do you feel I'm terrified I'm terrified
but also I'm trying to be grateful cuz
I'm like when am I ever going to get
this opportunity again to have six
strangers just come up to me and Riz me
try to be positive I've never been or
rised on so sorry sorry not
not oh we making a heart okay this
is okay there's some contact there that
wasn't bad I kind of like the little
physical
touch oh did you bring me
something oh did you write a love
letter he's
writing you seem nice
oh can I thank you or I don't know why
I'm yelling thank you thank you okay it
was cute you know what I think in my
head I'm thinking like okay I'm at a
coffee shop I'm studying I have my
headphones on and like somebody like
passes me a note it was kind of cute it
was like
hwome oh we're hugging okay this is
wonderful that was a nice warm bear
hug yeah is is there more do I get more
than a hug or
thanks oh are you Christian to or oh
sorry nice nice firm
handshake okay I feel like we're just
miming
is
okay oh okay that was pretty good that's
a good miming oh okay okay no that's
fine I played along cuz it was fun he's
a great mimer but I'm like am I supposed
to feel something cuz I just felt very
dry like I'm like okay what else
next
oh is this for
me wait I just got proposed
to I mean yeah I accept I do
yeah oh we got
the are you looking for something
or oh okay A little puppy
dog okay I
guess okay that wasn't bad that wasn't
bad I personally am like a physical
touch person I don't know if everybody
else is so on me that worked okay I'm
going to put you three cuz there was
cute a little letter but it wasn't
really Riz but it was it was adorable it
was like wholesome so I think that's
like a
good
median you you Mom mimed um are you from
P you is this like a French thing like
the miming okay but
last um The Proposal cute um is it Riz
though or did you just get on one
knee I I don't even know either I'm
going to put you forth it was still it
was still so
cute you gave me the hug right I'll put
you to cuz the hug was nice it was like
a nice little like friendly thing
actually no I'm going to put you further
down cuz I'm realizing like if I didn't
know you and you just came up to me and
hugged me I would I would call the
nearest police station cuz it was still
like friendly and you you give great
hugs uh you two switch Love Letter can
go here heart can go here the hand kiss
it was cute it was cute it come on it it
was cute it was the most like contac dis
I I got and it was very like h I was
giving like 1950s when they'd be like oh
mm moiselle so but I think this is good
Paris proposal bear hug letter heart
hand gestures kiss on the hand I think's
pretty good right oh hey my love print
is r i EEG which is lavender oh you
don't you don't know what that is then
you better download the nectar
app hi hi hi what's up I'm moose
nice to meet you it's so nice to meet
you it's a pleasure your smile is like
just brighten in my day like this room
is right but you brighten in my day with
that smile so I actually have a little
secret that I have to tell you what's
the secret which it's that actually I
came all the way here from a place that
you might know just to get some time
with you which is Toronto oh that really
yeah oh yeah look they said if they want
he wanted to he would and I did so I
could I been I went all the way on a
flight just to come here and spend some
time with you so wow are actually from
Toronto yeah where you from Toronto are
you oh my god well I live like I live
like a few City you said Ontario Canada
so I know that's not the six no I'm from
Durham but like nobody knows that no one
going to say Durham region out here yeah
I feel you I feel you okay what do you
do for fun how do you enjoy your life
what you what you enjoy your life I like
reading okay I like playing piano that's
very nice um I want to learn guitar
though we could do some piano and I
could sing some vocals for you like okay
you sing yeah I can sing a little bit
you can sing now oh I can't serenade you
on the first date like this that's like
you want you want me to sing for you
right now I mean I mean I don't know if
I could do all that if he wanted do he
would oh damn it's like that it's like
that okay well what's well okay I'll how
about how about we end this with the
song by want do you do you speak any
other languages
uh did you do like French no no
uh oh no no no by myself learning no I
learned by myself yeah it's not bad I
speak Arabic too you know I got multiple
languages
like not I can tell you my eyes and the
other thing that I can speak Is Your
Love Languages so I got to know what
those is I know you like physical touch
yeah physical is pretty good M you're
going to be in Toronto so I'm going to
see you there are you actually from
Toronto I swear to God I told you I flew
all the way out here just to meet
you hi Deb I'm Danny hi Danny nice to
meet you okay you didn't like my letter
I loved it it it was it was it seemed
like you hated my letter it was it was
okay but it wasn't like didn't make me
feel anything okay fine fine well I have
more things written down is that okay
yeah okay there's a chance that I Riz
you right and then we fall in love and
we get married and then you turn out to
be like a monster okay following right
has it ever happened to you sure yeah
have you guys ever dated someone who
turned out to be a
Monster yeah everyone strong so I don't
want that to happen again right so I put
together a preis interview exam pre can
you put that here preis interview exam I
didn't study okay what prescription
medications are you on uh I guys it's a
joke it's a joke the pry can't be funny
too the Proctor can't make a joke it's
fine okay real questions you
ready what's the favorite thing what's
your favorite thing about yourself um I
think I'm pretty open-minded it's good
quality yeah good quity I hope that's
good I'm rocking with that I'm with you
hey do you guys
mine okay last time you cried and why um
okay I cried this morning you CED this
morning cuz you were nervous for this
why did you actually cry this morning I
got my period okay I feel like that's
worthy yeah and I was like I wanted to
wait till like next week but it came
early and like you can never choose you
can't choose what I understand you can
never choose exactly you would know cuz
you get all the time right well you know
I just I hear things do the great fun
and I listen that's my best quality why
did your last relationship end I've
never been in a relationship before who
why do you think that is cuz you're a
Monster yeah I mean I've got big fangs
and no I'm kidding I think I just never
really had the chance I guess I don't
know but you just never had the chance
or never had the interest in a person uh
nobody's really asked me out or anything
so I guess that's a chance I guess that
leads me to my to my Riz moment okay
would you like to go on a date with me
sure where are we
going I haven't decided yet I didn't
know if you're going to say yes but do I
need to do a test too cuz what if you're
the monster that's a great Point okay so
give do we have more time
no and now I don't know you could be the
monster yeah I didn't really get the
approach like I get it was an exam maybe
I just didn't study enough for it but
he's cute like guess sorry sorry I don't
know I feel bad I'm like you're cute
though all right well quick preface for
the fellas this is not for the faint of
heart or the best way to rise a girl you
should probably just get to know her but
I'm going to Freestyle a little
something for you okay period do it I I
don't usually freestyle this close or
like seren second closer yeah let's do
it just look damn de you way too far
yeah damn de way too far n nah yeah yeah
damn damn de way to F you ain't no damn
n you aing damn d man so tell me what
you like yeah tell me what you like oh I
like reading books yes she like reading
books romance and novels romance and
novel so I'm me man you know I'm going
Full Throttle in the Camry in the whip
man you know she a model got the model
bottle body I would have to tell shot
that you looking too far for me to ever
I'm spinning yeah you looking damn
lovely and tell me do you like that
bubbly I love that bubbly yeah and you
know that I love how bubbly she is and
she got them lips and she got them eyes
man I'd love to give a kiss but I don't
know if I got a the r for his cuz you
know I got to be up in his
sh good no that was really good I'm
sorry about the the romance I didn't
know how to rap I don't I'm not going
romance no is totally better than
calling the cops on me but uh do you
have any
siblings right what I want to get to
know de bro the these are the real
questions bro I'm done with the memes
that was really good no that was really
good for a freestyle I was
like oh was I allowed to do that yeah
you're all good thank you uh my ball
rolled over here hi my name's a hi
what's your name I'm Deb nice to meet
you Deb you have gorgeous eyes by the
way thank you um not to be that guy
where did you get your earrings those
are really nice Claire's I'm not going
to lie to you I got my ears pierced
there when I was a kid from Claire's one
piercing no both oh wow so where are you
from from Ontario Canada wait where are
you from I didn't I'm from Cali I'm from
the bay but I actually uh was visiting
the Midwest just recently come see me oh
girl I got you I got you so am I coming
to Ontario cuz you got a storm right now
yeah you coming to Ontario flying that
storm so what's your favorite activity
uh I like reading what's your what's
your favorite last book that you read H
it I don't it's like a it was it's a
romance it's kind of like a a whatpad
are you believing I would know the book
yeah but it's like do you know what smut
is no like like okay do do okay it's
like a book but it's like like a spicy
book
like okay the Bible the Bible it was the
Bible no you can't do that now hello hey
okay so the proposal thing was a little
bit much I'm not going to lie a little
yeah I didn't know you like why are you
proposing I know but maybe it's
foreshadowing I don't know for sure so
how long are you in town for I'm leaving
in 6 hours well sh um well after this
this will be done in like two hours then
are you one of those people that gets to
the airport like early or you like like
the chance I like the chance I like the
swi of almost missing my flight that is
what I'm talking about okay so here's
what I'm thinking right we WRA this
thing up these guys are great but like
you should pick me for sure for sure I
figured we go out we have some drinks do
you drink I do F oh wait can you
no no swearing fantastic that's amazing
so I say we go get some drinks somewhere
somewhere in Hollywood and then we'll
like hit a few spots gradually getting
closer to the airport oh my God okay
it's pre-planning it's pre-planning I
like this you're organized and we'll get
to know each other without cameras in
the room so that we can get like serious
we can say profanity ooh like what
like that's a bad one I'm sorry that was
a bad one I'm sorry they got be that's a
lot to beep out sorry sorry editors no
but we keep we we do that we have some
drinks we have a great time I drop you
off at your flight you go there you're
like damn I had so much fun you're going
to be like I missed my flight and then
we continue to drink and have great like
a great day the rest of the day I mean
yeah and then you you book my next
flight cuz sure why not you made me miss
this one I can do that that's not a
problem okay and then you proposed to me
I guess the day after or no no no no I
don't like to move that fast okay we
could start with like making out or
something okay like nice and light yeah
not too much tongue proposal yeah just
right there yeah good job I just thought
he was funny I'm a big banter person so
the fact that he was able to like go off
of me really well I was into it wow I I
love this white void we're in right now
Jack nice to meet you I know nice to
meet you jack you know fun fact you're
actually not allowed to like greet me if
you're on a plane why cuz if like
someone walks up to me and says hijack
everyone in the plane is going to start
like freaking out oh okay yeah I'll make
sure I could go by Paris though Paris
why Paris you're saying I was doing the
mime thing okay you know what you look
like a Paris I look like a a Paris have
you been to Paris no I haven't okay I've
never been out of the country I don't
even have a passport I mean maybe I need
to like BR my horizons I need to start
reading smut though honestly oh my God
what was the last smut thing you read um
okay well was it like a your name kind
of thing yeah like w yeah yeah wait what
do you know about book like I know
things I've you read smart no I don't
read you read pad SM no I used to okay
when I was like 14 I was like really
into Sonic the Hedgehog and I'll just
leave it at that
leave it at that yeah yeah yeah does
this do anything is this doing anything
right now what what is this Sonic the
Hedgehog fanfiction yeah it's doing a
lot for me yeah I'm feeling a a lot of
yeah yeah so anyway
SM n keep it running I got it uh okay
okay do you like uh movies I do like
movies yes that's great and the time's
out right now so I'm going to step back
over there really nice meeting nice to
meet you that was and that's how you do
it gentlemen that's how you do
it have you watched Horton here a who
are you saying I look like Jojo from
years okay sorry it's been I've been
wanting to say it for the last like hour
it's it's a compliment though done it
before I'm here for it the real question
is do you find JoJo attractive yeah I
had a crushed him when I was when I was
young bro that's what I'm
saying I was kind of distracted since he
looked like Horton here's a h and I was
like can you please sing for me like I
need you to start singing so you can
relive my childhood memories all right
what's up yay first of all good job guys
um I'm going to start with last place
just because this one suck out to me as
like a clear last place no offense all
impressive but Joe Goldberg or um what
was sorry that's you that's from you
have you never seen you he's a serial
killer have you seen oh cool I'll put
you over yeah and honestly you seem
sweet and you're you're very goodlook so
like you know it was the the exam quiz
that's fine um I think I got to protect
my own who I ra and I don't think you
can ever be too careful so I'm fine with
this I'm going to be honest I this feels
like you're protecting yourself from
being a monster oh my God and you're
projecting your serial killer isms onto
me u i was focused on my questions and I
was focused on my evaluation and I think
I got the answers I was looking for guys
good luck to
you I'm proud of all of you uh I'm going
to let you stay there for fifth that's
okay it was cute but it didn't really
feel feel any RZ and I I didn't feel
like you asked me any much questions I
feel like I got to know you well though
if I was if I was like interviewing you
for the job I would have definitely
hired you you got that corporate Riz bro
you got that corporate yes like you got
that LinkedIn
RZ I feel
like a lot of people won't agree with me
but I'm going to get you do to
switch damn I love loved the rap it was
so impressive it's too gimmicky like I'd
rather just get to know you yeah I guess
that's kind of like where I was going
but like if I was like Simon cow and
like America's Got Talent I would
definitely hit the golden buzzer but I
didn't feel any like buzz inside of me
like there's a better way to word that
there's definitely better way to word
like that sentence and the rap was
insane I'm probably going to like you
got to record that and send it to me cuz
I need some ego boost in no way I'm
going to finish a song for fourth place
bro smoking hell no it was
good make a whole song and record it it
was good I would love that on like the
third date you know but immediate Riz I
was like I didn't really ain't going to
be a third date okay okay I'm sorry
Landon yes I think I'm going to leave
you there I thought you were really
funny and that's kind of just like my
type in people completely fine and we
still getting drinks after this though
yeah are you going to buy my flight
after you make me miss it sure that's
completely fine with me you know I'm I'm
I'm okay with that you know I'm in the
middle kind of plus those those two that
were next to me they were some
goodlooking fellows all right and I am
uh I operate off personality the last
I'm not good at
this I like both of you guys I like the
the like the soccer ball like uh hey you
got my ball it was very like wholesome
and it was casual and I feel like I was
like immediately comfortable with you
but you made like such insane eye
contact like like it just felt like I
was actually like I don't know it was
just very it was very intense but like I
love the approach for you but I liked
how like you Incorporated I don't know
how to explain it so I don't
really stop looking at
me
do go with where your heart wants go
with what your heart wants
uh I think I'm going
to I think I'm going to go with you a
for first
place listen three languages second
place okay that's cool with me I'm still
at the top of the ladder but I put him
second only because it started to feel
forced halfway through it kind of felt
like he searched up like how to r a girl
Google wey how and then did that on me
but it was so wholesome both of you guys
are so like wholesome but yours just
felt so like natural and like
comfortable so you're my first place for
this episode I guess appreciate
[Music]
that amazing feeling I mean it's a
little shocking I won't lie I mean you
know between a rapper notepad I mean it
was stiff
competition